I turned to my right Miami born Miami
bred Miami strong he is right now one of
the best in the business in UFC the BMF
champion if you will the UFC he is none
other than Jorge MOSFET all good to see
you bud how are you good man how you
guys doing I'm doing fine you got a lot
of fans right here in Miami
so let me ask you where where should I
go in this town
you were telling me you great Moscow
doll was my tour guide where would I go
in Miami Florida take you to Latin food
you have to eat the Latin food here
don't you got it the best in the country
oh you don't have the best Mexican food
or Italian food but every other Latin
dish we master it and we do better than
anybody else
okay so definitely some Cuban food maybe
okay Colombian food is pretty good here
too any Latin American food that's done
here Dominican food is just amazing so
if you had to choose something for me to
I could only have one Latin dish what
would it be for him I'll spin off this
Super Bowl week what should I have right
if you ask you me I am I'm getting the
pork chops with the rice and beans
little Tony's which is like fried
plantains avocado and then you got to
get a milkshake man that comes with this
no she's not a milkshake Euler we like
ice cream it's uh you know you got to
get the coffee as well but you also bang
the guy see you guys are nodding your
head behind the cameras over there
yeah no these guys are Miami boys ain't
no I'm talking about food lunching for
like another two I see it is normally
we're used to finishing our show and
having lunch on the west coast but now
we're here on the East Coast all right
so that's what I should go seek out
tonight yeah all right is there anything
you can do about the traffic around here
didn't know I'm not even mean not even
you Jesus to do anything that's Miami
traffic I get used to it
hey congrats on winning a Grammy Award
man Congrats on that was amazing that
people didn't know about that I had
another side something how about that I
mean
you have a musical side what's this guy
what's this guy's name dance Myers got
up there and his red tuxedo and he
looked just like you and then how many
people are like congratulating you on
your Grammy Award for this week I'm
taking it you know people congratulating
me on and they're asking me for a
picture feeling that's happened like
twice already
and I was just completely thrown off at
first I'm just going with enough -
before it yeah you know you're right
about that Grammy did you get you got it
no you got a Grammy Award now I got a
Grammy Award knows that's not so what a
thought yeah I don't know if you'd ever
go for the best country duo/group but
that's exactly who you won supposedly
your Grammy for about this right now
yep I read a little bit about it look
like put a picture up for that I know
it's one of the tech guys come on it's
good by the way
Jorge Hospital is calling out our
control room right now in Los Angeles
and we should put this damn thing up
right there somebody ran in the audience
needs to see we will get on that right
now
see humming so are you a country music
fan or not really or we got already got
for me there's one good country song I
like god Bless America something but I'm
not - I would say uh
right knowledgable in country music okay
you're not so what is your music that
you listen to latin music mostly mainly
like 70% of the day's Latin music so
it's not you're not into Irish rock
you're not an Irish right now haven't
haven't got cuz that's what conor
mcgregor's into I think I don't think so
why aren't you fighting Conor McGregor
Jorge must at all you can't ask me that
you gotta ask on it you know the the the
company UFC has a president right mm-hmm
like the CEO whatever they want to call
him and when they asked him why the
fights not happening he said it in the
nicest way possible and he said I was
too much man for meaning I'm too much
man for him I can't ask this guy to
fight me and it was just it is what it
is you know so for those who might not
understand that you're too much man for
him he's basically saying what that
you're your weight size is too much for
Conor McGregor is that what he said my
will my size my determination makes him
with I'm not a quitter I've never typed
in my life you know
it's a different type of dog over here
you know I'm too much man from in every
way that that could possibly be said it
sounded like he was calling you out
after he beat cowboy Cerrone it sounded
like he was pointing to you and he was
calling that's a call out man and I was
like I was like a scared to call out man
I was like not really you know I don't
think that was a caller and our
management have been talking back and
forth it's not in their future it's not
something they want well he wants khabib
to find him first
right yeah and that's good for him go go
do you think I'll go back down to your
division do whatever you're gonna do
whether you're gonna win or lose that's
none of my business go do your stuff but
at 170 there's only one sheriff in town
that's you Jorge's moshpit dog now go
you don't have to ask that huh so are
you saying just are you saying Conor
McGregor is scared of you like literally
if you got him in a room he just would
really would not want a piece of you you
realize that I'm not saying he's scared
because any anybody that gets him that
makes that walk that gets into the cage
that fights champions how he's fine he's
not to be scared but he knows it's it's
not a good outcome why gamble it up you
know you just got a win in go get
another win have fun he said it in the
interview himself he doesn't feel up to
speed he's not up to par yet so let him
go get ready while he's doing that
there's this guy that's going around
saying that he has a championship I'm
gonna go take it I'm gonna I'm gonna
take that guy's belt it's not saying
he's winning a championship have you
fought your Frankie read your next
opponent or who yeah yeah it was
business I forgot his name but uh
what's-his-face Guzman yeah
he's gonna get body I'm gonna be I'm
gonna say name is Camaro huisman I'm
Barry said in the bedroom and he's a
welterweight champ
he's the welterweight champ but he's
soon to be on crown you know and let him
enjoy his moment now that he has the
belt he's at the pinnacle of his life
right cuz from here it's only it's a
violent way down you did see what Conor
McGregor did to cowboy Cerrone right you
did see that right yeah it was front row
right you saw me like no you were right
there so why
what makes you so confident did you see
what I did the cowboy in his prime
yes no I'm just asking you what made you
what makes you so confident that you
could take care of it it's skills it's
really it in a fight if you don't know
too much about fighting might sound
cocky like oh this guy's just cocky but
a good football coach that seeing
openings constantly goes remember we can
run the ball and we could throw it we
get all this craziness it's just it's
just math to me man and when I see
Connor I see a lot of holes from from a
stand technical point but I'm not from
I'm a coach and I'm advising my athlete
best way to beat this guy I see many
math senator what do you say what do you
mean by math scenarios you see the X's
and O's here is what I see X's and O's I
see the square root of his space times -
I see all these things constant now I
didn't know we were gonna get a map
where we write this down this is like
the only thing almost ivana when it
comes to fighting I have like multiple
and everybody here I have like a number
on their face division multiplication is
just something that they God gifted me
with so I'm really good at it what does
my face say to you you have all types of
numbers openings state but you know
things that I think I'm like man I think
you take a better shot on this side so
I'm gonna hit him on this side all that
type of man but you haven't you haven't
gotten in his stance with me yet it's
basically you're saying again just
looking at my face uh-huh first of all
reading the body language all that stuff
thank you for not saying big fat zero
that's number one number two is just
like you see numbers when you're looking
at my I see somebody can take a good
punch man he looks like you take a good
one so you gotta give like a like four
or five to the face before you know you
know what I'm looking out for the
shoulder to the nose that's what I'm
looking out for so Mike you see you see
holes and in conversation I see I not
not that his game is not good because
this game is great but I just when I do
the math and I see the numbers in my
head and and and I see the openings that
I could take advantage of I lean towards
me very heavy you know or have Moscow
doll here on the Rich Eisen show how did
you get how did you get the nickname for
those I don't know game Brett how did
that come from where the game Brett well
first game because um a lot of people
don't know what it means the game means
the ability to fight through pain or
fatigue doesn't mean how good you are
fighting it means that you could fight
those elements that you can be tired and
you can get hurt and push through it and
bread you know you you got a German
Shepherd with another German Shepherd
you bred a German Shepherd you know so
that's that's the meaning of it and I've
had the name since since before I turned
pro it's a dog term and I love dogs and
my brother recommended it to music that
should be your nickname it's kind of
your fighting side the time I wasn't
that skill that was more of a of a
willful individual you just had a lot of
will so it's talking it's it's Who I am
you know right so who gave it to you you
remember who gave it to you is it
somebody just yes your brother you said
your brother gave it yeah okay and when
was your first fight how'd you get first
started um first fight was if you asked
my dad it was in preschoolers like in
the daycare and cold on the side yeah
you know my dad says that I would watch
come for movies out Saturday and Sunday
and then on Monday just wait for a kid
to take my building blocks or whatever
and it was that's it at same time so so
basically there's a preschool here in
the city of Miami yes that you went to
do you remember the name of it I went I
went to like five or six this is from my
dad's calculations I I've been kicked
out by like four or five by the time I
was four okay
and all for the same thing something
related with was a fisticuffs so you
basically turn to preschool into your
own personal octagon it's pretty much
okay pretty so somebody was sending
their four-year-old to a preschool here
in Miami and they're like that Mossman
all kid yeah it's got to be stopped
essentially what happened and if you ask
my dad which is the best part I was
never in the wrong he's like man you
were such a good kid these kids always
came into I have no recollection and
stuff but in my dad's eyes I was never
in the line every once in a row
sounds like a high quality parenting
right there yeah damn Skippy
okay so outside of preschool your first
actual fight like a mature pair like
where you're like you know what I'm
gonna try and make some cash out of this
I'm gonna take these skills and I'm
gonna try and become game bred I'm gonna
try and become Jorge MOSFET all who sees
holes in Conor McGregor's game that guy
holes in his face holes in his face yeah
right holes in his face my bad
18 is my first pro fight okay but I was
fighting way before that no wait wait
before that like like somebody that
likes basketball would would have a
pickup game bigger picture I'd you know
put the gloves on and spar or fight with
individuals you know if we could arrange
it so I had many many bouncing even the
backyard fights were before that mmm the
backyard fights that I had in Kimball's
backyard so what did it mean for you to
be to take the BMF belt and have it put
on you by the rock
it's and we're aren't when we're on live
radio and television for those who have
a center of the BMF belt just to give
you an idea no I know I know we can't
say the okay some certain words yes
but the belt in itself is one at a one
and then we got my favorite action star
and it's actually a great person as well
the rock putting the belt on me it's a
one out of one moment in history to me
you know I don't know how the world
views and stuff but to me it's a very
special moment in history we actually
got some nice memorabilia for that I got
a nice section in the office set up for
that it's a very impactful day in my
life
mmm okay and and so you have a Super
Bowl prediction here in Miami
you got one for me looking at my manager
cuz I don't know much about folk I don't
watch TV man I can't tell you wait a min
your watch tell me I don't watch TV what
do you do five like I train I eat I have
friends I promise but do I have friends
I swear okay you're just not here I
train I train a lot you know and then
when I do got downtime I spend a lot of
it with my family and then right back to
the gym so what was the last television
show you watched
I mean you have watched I have watched
seven so the last TV show that you're
like you know what I'm
I'm sit down one yeah and the things
that when I also a reason why I don't
watch TVs if I see something I like I'm
binging I'm just gonna watch your
personality they're no longer like it
when the show's over
so that's another reason why I'm
watching but the last show that I saw
they had me hooked was a American Horror
Story that thing is very disturbing oh
yeah yeah yeah I loved it though man it
was it was right before the knife and I
hadn't watch TV like in two years and I
saw like a little preview of and I was
like damn they got me two years so
American Horror Story before you fight
Nate I mean that had to play into you
had to bring it to real life you know
the American Horror Story American harsh
Longman uh Nate's face that's a good
thing I guess before you're fighting it
wasn't like paw Patrol or something like
that some sort of kids TV show or
anything like that that have been really
odd yeah puppy puppy power to the to the
you could see I've got an 11 8 6 year
old homeless stuff that I've see on
television I've seen I've seen a lot of
those - I got an 11 and a 5 real slice -
okay so you see yeah but them also
they're very limited on the TV so they
kind of like walk is it too busy
wrecking a preschool or what with you
right no no my five-year-old son was
maybe the first six months the
transition just I thought he was gonna
exactly be like me yeah
but he's gotten so much better now we're
so happy with him when he comes home and
there was no disturbance at school like
he just went under the radar
we have celebrations for this local
loose start sorry about them
[Music]
close thanks for coming on Jorge Jorge
moss but I'll add game bred fighter on
both Twitter and Instagram right here on
their chest
we're back with Frank Caliendo yeah what
do you got right there what are you
holding up this is my mascot I have my
own miss Kyle so if you want to drink
some some greatness yeah here you go
what's in the bottle what's available
what is it called I can't see recuerdo
recuerdo whoa Oh give me the PMF belt
now I just said those words into a mouth
no hint of irony very cool weirdo right
that what is that's on me you said it so
good a MOSFET all right here on the rich
eyes that you I get myself an
autographed version of it right here for
those playing at home very good for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app